who were by Philip Winkler this is not a
book for the faint-hearted this debut
novel is about beating people up and
being beaten about soccer fans who are
out of control hooligans who meet for
rumbles outside stadiums varoom diesel
gevalia why this violence why do people
do it become when does it start as a
vision listen Beck rock background as
someone had or have to have to become a
part of this scene I in sukham pool is
the story of an outsider hi call his
father is an alcoholic his mother ran
off abandoning the family haiku has
failed his school-leaving exams twice
all he has is anger and rage or he
thinks his capable of his fighting and
organizing fights each Pokemon Sun shots
in the hunt if I kept mini hunt flesh
and blood I exist pause it and hi Sam
Smith's is it so if off hopefully it's
not that's why to wonder
the tone of the novel is as rough as
haiku substitute family the hooligans
themselves be my star by tundish park of
opposed to the work when it came to the
language was to find a balance to keep
it from going too far in a verbal
idiomatic direction but also to avoid
sounding too literary and artificial
Quinn stifling bit by bit Philip Finkler
put together a psycho gram of a young
man who can't find words to express his
feelings instead haiku expresses himself
with violence pool doesn't shy away from
pain while also revealing a yearning for
love friendship and family vida furnace
or encounter by Buddha kirchhof
a man and a woman he has retired from
publishing she has given up her hat shop
two lonely people in their 50s meet and
spontaneously decide to take a trip
together under since Y mentioned the
entropy hasta it seems as if time has
left these two people behind but
together they experience something that
abruptly catapults them into the here
and now hide he nine juiced they
traveled further and further to the
southernmost tip of Italy and suddenly
they discovered something that they no
longer expected love hovey enviar una
adversary Bichette Song yi de vieja new
ensign in Doha and flushed nning for
them liebe but then current reality
bursts into their idyllic world they
come across a girl begging issue refugee
they decide to take her along with them
a dire mistake and they find out that
their dream of a happy family life was
just an illusion
finish my Mustafa Nanda Parbat stood I
wanted to tell a parable lines them
goals within a limited space send with
minimal means I wanted to tell a tale
about what the wider world does with us
about how our private lives in the
public world don't go together Sue's I'm
in gate
boroka coughs novel depicts two people
setting off on an adventure and failing
within the space of four days
but in the end they're given a chance to
begin anew I'm Lana CR or a long year by
ever Schmidt how does one capture
everyday life a sense of all that
surrounds us the ordinary moments that
make up our lives that is what fo
Schmidt attempted to do in n la ng ser
her first novel in 19 years gabon
drosophila unless upon I know there were
just so many other things going on in a
very large complicated family and I just
didn't have the frame of mind right off
i-95 things were more important stiga
the slave life was more important set in
a single City the lives of its
inhabitants intertwined in the book
thirty eight episodes depict overwhelmed
parents drinkers and dreamers who all
reside in a dreary high-rise housing
complex I involve la crisi huntin and on
that vision Vega d how's Norman one of
the facade demult în recency fan on
don't Ashley confirm the house n Ganga
first aired Meek Mill containing far
Eden yer impul people live in close
proximity but yet somehow unconnected
their eyes meet in the stairwell or
across balconies the gaze of intimate
strangers yeah Cynthia Felicia there are
a lot of very lonely people that's
probably why so many of them have dogs
at some point I thought there are too
many dogs I can't have that but then I
wasn't able to leave any of them out
wanted a 94 kind in reckless
that's what characterizes Aoife
Schmidt's writing it doesn't need much
and yet has it all and not a single
detail can be excluded it's summer it's
hot and there's lots of free time it's
1985 in android kuba checks novel and a
group of young boys drifts through a
short summer of anarchy in the middle of
a prefab residential tract fans an
awesome matsu stunt on digital
communication time is not the norm
especially in this book because the hero
gets to enjoy his vacation without any
supervision here's a lot of money too
doesn't get much better than that for a
16 year old it's a story about growing
up trying to find your way and falling
in love girls play a role of course
especially a girl with no name
learning love friendship that's what the
summer of 85 is about and the right
music although not everything is
sweetness and sunshine khandwa nadas el
dandee melancholy and fill the include
monster Gershwin mosquitoes kinda an
impressive income in melancholy tune
mere water h2o melancholy our understand
fest that I mayor vatika Cassandra
singing that image music in my village
this is an intense book about first love
and hearts running wild in a country
that would cease to exist just a few
years later East Germany get it ash
puter actually east germany plays only a
minor role it's shown the way a young
person would have seen it back then as
perfectly ordinary in the end the goal
gets the name and the Boyer becomes his
melancholy at least until the end of the
summer anti-coup b.tech tells his story
in a laid-back style and without any
false sentiment
divert important for the world at your
back by Thomas mellow how does one enjoy
the abyss of depression and the sensory
overload of being manic in his novel
debate in houghton Thomas Miller has
written about his bipolar disorder and
his struggle against shame fear and
delusion I thought oh not that I simply
had to write this because my whole life
and all my writing were determined by
this disorder I had to wipe the slate
clean
lavon's NSN fragen katsu stands under
Constantine Dhawan vovokan hora moans
it's a DA honking stars she could have
an estimate so classy dimension son and
so they are their own belief in Kingston
der dinger objective in asteroids
austral as plastic minor errands in Cabo
they can each mushroom oz etawah in his
manic phases he believes he has slept
with Madonna and sees messages
everywhere everything seems to speak to
him we experience both his highs and
lows writing is a form of exorcism a way
of restoring some hope
this I try to do everything I can with
language to turn on the great manic
machine without becoming manic myself
you just have to accept the fear and
grabs ahold of me again and again even
while I was writing this book this book
shouts out this is how it was with me
and I hope that it will never be that
way again Amanda Show not satisfied
money and it wrote a very nice to
believe harbor java verdict leader his
mark michuda um bring born opened fun
than that is 10 of vital him
friend azilla donk levert or dark forest
a foreign soul by Reinhardt Kaiser new
lacquer
hien hard kizamu edgar wright's about
the present but his books seem as though
they're from the past his a farmer's son
from Upper Austria and his latest novel
is called femme de Cielo donk levert
evade the swim prescribe was walking the
world I try to write about again in
magana is one that I know very well it's
one that I grew up in and that I think
very few people are familiar with the
rustic world of a farm worked for
several generations is hardly idyllic a
father sells off the family land piece
by piece the grandfather revels in
playing the patriarch and two brothers
are stuck in the middle of it all p not
v deterrent is from the autobahn here
Johnson bass heroic yah dis Chile
bazooka first unheimlich as varied as
own better from 4-9 for clothes and un
betta son on a neat twist Egan given T
busy here on kapahulu
the characters are imprisoned by their
background and their religion they leave
but they never make any progress
everywhere there is silence and
emotional Antinous as modern life rushes
past the family when up nine you only
have one language just as you only have
one family background and you don't get
to choose it but you can capture people
and landscapes in words pine had kizamu
occur does so with precision and without
romanticizing anything
you